Chefs are the world's worst delegators; so we have these sort of recipes in our mind...
...that we're not very good at writing down and becoming consistent.
The importance of putting recipes together establishes a consistent high mark...
...in terms of cooking standards.
So putting a recipe together, fine tuning it is paramount.
Teaching somebody that recipe is even greater.
The art of success in terms of business is delegation.
I've got 1,750 chefs and waiters in my team and I need to teach young chefs...
...the importance of how to cook properly.
The first thing you do is teach them how to taste.
If you don't understand how it tastes perfectly, then you shouldn't be cooking it.
But if you know how something tastes perfectly, you cook it ten times better.
So, we have a bit of an old-fashioned scenario: you focus on taste, and then we cook.